(upbeat music)
- It was amazing.
- One sentence,
I don't think I'll ever forget in my life,
Mom, I made it to Harvard.
It was like a Bollywood
Hollywood kind of a sentence.
- Well I'm Shrey.
I'm a freshman in Harvard, Class of 2022.
And I'm from New Delhi, India.
I've been using Khan
Academy for quite a while,
6th grade, probably.
(uplifting music)
Chemistry is a subject that,
if you're not clear with the fundamentals
or the building blocks,
you will really struggle a lot
when you get to the higher concepts.
When I struggled with Chemistry,
it was more about not
getting enough attention
on the basic fundamental things,
or the class being just
too fast-paced for me.
(upbeat music)
Khan Academy eliminated that
for me to a great extent,
'cause I didn't have to feel bad
about watching the same
video over and over again.
I could watch it at a slower pace.
I could do millions of questions
at the same level, at
the fundamental level,
and that was great, actually,
'cause I was learning at my own pace.
(electronic chime)
Khan Academy teaching just eliminates
any sort of learning gap.
- This access to education
is the greatest gift
which we can give to our kids,
wherever they are in this world.
If they have access to
this kind of education
through technology, through digital means,
through platforms like Khan Academy,
they can achieve anything.
A child sitting in any
corner of the world,
if they have this access
to these resources,
anything is possible.